مساء الخير،
بدأت الدعوة العباسية دعوة سرية في نهاية القرن الأول للهجرة،
في عهد الخليفة الأموي عمر بن عبد العزيز،
وتزعمها محمّد بن علي بن عبد الله بن العباس،
وهو من احفاد العباس بن عبد المطلب عم الرسول.
اتخذ العباسيون ثلاثة مراكز رئيسية لدعوتهم السرية،
وهي مدن؛
الكوفة بالعراق،
والحُميمة بالأردن حاليا،
وخراسان ببلاد فارس.
سيقود دعوتهم اثنا عشر (12) نقيبا،
أقسموا على الولاء لإمام الدعوة محمد بن علي بن عبد الله بن العباس،
بعد وفاة هذا الأخير سنة 125 هجرية سيوصي بالإمامة لإبنه ابراهيم،
وستتحوّل معه الدعوة العباسية من السريّة إلى العلنية،
و يصبح ابو سلمة الخلال في الكوفة،
وأبو مسلم الخراساني في بلاد فارس،
من اهم رموزها.
سنة 127هـ
عُقد في مكّة اجتماع هامّا،
ضمّ كلّ فروع البيت الهاشمي المعادي للبيت الأموي،
وضمّ العباسيين (أحفاد العباس عم الرسول)،
والعلويين ( أحفاد علي بن ابي طالب)،
والجعفريين (أحفاد جعفر بن أبي طالب)،
والعَقِيليين (احفاد عَقِيل بن أبي طالب).
كان هدف الإجتماع هو توحيد الصف الهاشمي
لإعادة الحُكم إلى آل البيت.
أقرّ المجتمعون أن تكون الدعوة ضد الأمويين «هاشمية»،
لا علوية ولا عباسية،
وشعارها هوّ؛ «الرضا من آل البيت»،
واتفقوا انه بعد ازاحة بني أمية
تكون الخلافة من نصيب محمد النفس الزكية،
حفيد الحسن بن علي بن أبي طالب.
مع تعاظم انتشار الدعوة العباسية،
شعُر الخليفة الأموي مروان بن محمّد بالخطر الداهم،
فأمر سنة 128 هجرية
بالقاء القبض على زعيم الدعوة ابراهيم بن محمد بن عبد الله بن العباس،
وايداعه السجن.
ابراهيم الإمام سيموت في سجن الأمويين في ظروف غامضة،
وسيوصي قبل وفاته بالإمامة من بعده
لأخيه أبي العباس عَبْد الله بن محمد بن علي.
بعد وفاة زعيمهم ابراهيم الإمام سنة 131 هجرية،
سيمرّ العبّاسيون إلى مرحلة الحسم العسكري مع بني أميّة.
وفى الحادي عشر من شهر جمادى الآخرة سنة 132 هـ،
ستدور  قرب نهر الزاب الكبير وهو أحد روافد نهر دجلة،
معركة حاسمة بين الخليفة الأموى الأخير مروان بن محمد
والأمير العباسي عبد الله بن علي،
انتهت المعركة بهزيمة جيش مروان بن محمد،
وفراره إلى مصر حيث سيُقتل فى منطقة أبو صير.
الإنتصارات العسكرية التي حققها العباسيون،
ستدفعهم إلى التنكّر لاتفاق مكّة
الذي ابرموه مع بقية فروع البيت الهاشمي،
والذي يقضي بمنح الخلافة للبيت العلوي،
وبالتحديد لمحمد النفس الزكية،
وسيعلن أبو العباس عبد الله بن علي نفسه خليفة على المسلمين
في الكوفة في الثاني عشر من شهر ربيع الأول من عام 132 هـ،
بعد أن ظهر إلى الناس في خطبة الجمعة قائلا:
إن الله رد علينا حقنا، وختم بنا كما افتتح بنا،
فاستعدّوا فأنا السفاح المبيح، والثائر المَنِيح... ".
ومنذ ذلك الحين أصبح يلقّب بأبي العباس السفاح.
يذكر فرج فودة في كتابه الحقيقة الغائبة،
ان أبي العباس السفاح، الخليفة المؤسس للدولة العباسية،
والذي امتدّ حكمه من 132 هجرية إلى 136 هجرية،
بدأ حُكمه بجريمتين دمويتين ليس لهما سابقة في التاريخ:
الجريمة الأولى؛
هي أمره بنبش قبور خلفاء بني أمية وإخراج جثثهم،
وجلدهم وصلبهم، ثمّ حرق الجثث ونثر رمادها في الريح.
يذكر ابن الأثير في كتابه الكامل في التاريخ،
الجزء الرابع، الصفحة 333،
ما يلي:
«أمر عبد الله بن علي( وهوعم السفاح وواليه على دمشق)،
بنبش قبور بني أمية في دمشق،
فنُبش قبر معاوية بن أبي سفيان،
فلم يجدوا فيه إلاّ خيطاً مثل الهباء.
ونُبش قبر يزيد بن معاوية،
فوجدوا فيه حطاماً كأنه الرماد.
ونُبش قبر عبد الملك بن مروان
فوجدوا جمجمته...
وأما هشام بن عبد الملك فإنه وُجدَ صحيحاً،
لم يَبْلَ منه إلاّ أرنبة أنفه،
فضربه بالسياط وصلبه وحرّقه وذرّاه في الريح».
الشيعة والزيديون،
نسبة إلى زيد بن علي،
اعتبروا ان بقاء جثة هشام بن عبد الملك كاملة سبع سنوات بعد دفنه،
هوّ معجزة إلاهية لتنفيذ القصاص العادل به،
لأنه أمر في  فترة حكمه بإخراج جثة زيد بن علي من قبره،
وصلبه على جذع شجرة أربعة سنوات،
قبل أن يأمر بحرق جثته.
أمّا الجريمة الثانية التي اركتبها ابو العباس السفاح،
ويذكرها ابن الأثبر أيضا،
فهي انه قام باستدراج  تسعين نفرا من كبار بني أمية
على رأسهم سليمان بن هشام بن عبد الملك،
وبعد ان أمّنهم على حياتهم وأحسن كرمهم في مجلسه،
دخل عليه شاعر يدعى سُدَيف،
وكان من المتعصّبين لبني هاشم،
فقال:
لا يغرّنك ما ترى من رجال
إن تحت الضلوع داء دويّا
فضع السيف وارفع السوط
حتّى لا ترى فوق ظهرها أمويا
فقال سليمان بن هشام بن عبد الملك لسُديف:
قتلتني يا شيخ.
امر ابو العباس السفّاح حرسه بضرب
كل الحاضرين في مجلسه من أمراء بني أمية
بأعمدة من حديد على رؤوسهم
ليظلّوا محتضرين بين الحياة والموت،
ثمّ امر بوضع مفارش مائدة الطعام فوق أجسادهم،
ليأكل ما لذّ وطاب،
ولسان حاله يقول:
ما أكلت أطيب من هذا الطعام.
أمام هذه الجرائم التي اقترفها أبو العباس السفاح،
يتساءل فرج فوده عن سرّ صمت الفقهاء في ذلك العصر،
صمت أبي حنيفة النعمان،
وصمت مالك ابن انس،
اما احمد بن حنبل،
فقد ذهب إلى حد رواية حديث منسوب للرسول يُنذر بخلافة السفاح،
حيث ذكر في مُسنده ما يلي:
قال رسول الله،
يخرج رجل من أهل بيتي عند انقطاع من الزمان وظهور من الفتن،
رجل يقال له السفاح فيكون إعطاؤه المال حَثْيا".
أبو العباس السفّاح سيتعقّب بني أميّة في كلّ مكان بهدف استئصالهم،
ولم ينجُ منهم إلا عبد الرحمن بن معاوية المُلقب بـعبد الرحمن الداخل،
الذى سيهرب إلى الأندلس ويؤسس الدولة الأموية الثانية.
الخليفة العباسي الأوّل أبو العبّاس السفّاح سينقل عاصمة الخلافة
من دمشق إلى الكوفة في بادئ الأمر ثمّ إلى الأنبار،
وسيجعل من ابي مسلم الخراساني والي خراسان أهم مساعديه،
وسيكلّفه بقتل وزيره أبي سلمة الخلاّل،
وهو من أبرز رموز الدعوة العباسية،
كما انه سيعتمد على عمه عبد الله بن علي والي الشام،
وعلى أخيه أبي جعفر المنصور.
السفّاح سيصاب بمرض الجُدَرِي ويُتَوفى سنة 136 هجرية،
ويترك الخلافة من بعده لأخيه أبي جعفر المنصور،
ليكون الخليفة الثاني للدولة العباسية،
بعد ان حُرم من ان يكون الخليفة الأوّل المؤسس،
لأنّه اكبر سنّا من أخيه السفّاح،
ولكن بني العبّاس بايعوا السفّاح لأن أمه حرّة عربية،
في حين كانت ام المنصور أمة وهى سلاّمة بنت بشير،
من قبيلة نفزاوة الأمازيغية.
يعتبر فرج فوده ان مكانة ابي جعفر المنصور عند العباسيين،
هي بمكانة معاوية بن أبي سفيان عند الأمويين،
فهو المؤسس الحقيقي للدولة العباسية.
اول تحدّ سيواجهه الخليفة العباسي الثاني ابو جعفر المنصور،
هو تمرّد عمّه عبد الله بن علي والي الشام،
الذي كان يرى انه أحق بالخلافة من أبي جعفر المنصور،
ورفض مبايعته،
وأعلن تمرُّده في الشام.
أبو جعفر المنصور سيرسل له جيشا
بقيادة أبي مسلم الخراساني ألحق به هزيمة نكراء،
هرب على إثرها عبد الله بن علي إلى البصرة
ليلتجئ إلى أخيه سليمان،
وبقي متخفيا مدة من الزمن،
قبل ان يظفر به المنصور ويسجنه،
ليموت في السجن سنة 147 هجرية.
بعد ان تخلّص من عمّه،
بدأ أبو جعفر المنصور
في التخطيط للتخلّص من الرجل القوي في خراسان،
ابي مسلم الخراساني،
الذي كانت له مكانة قوية في نفوس اتباعه من الفرس والعرب،
الرجل كان يتقن العربية و الفارسية على حد السواء،
وكان عالماً بأصول الشريعة والفقه،
إلى جانب،
انه كان وراء اهم الإنتصارات العسكرية لبني العباس على الأمويين.
تعاظم شأن أبي مسلم الخراساني بين الجند،
وأصبح يستخفّ بأوامر الخليفة أبي جعفر المنصور،
الذي لم ينس لأبي مسلم،
تجرّؤه على ان يطلب من أبي العباس السفاح
ان يأذن له بإمامة المسلمين في الحج سنة 136 هجرية.
بادئ ذي بدء،
رسم ابو جعفر المنصور خطة محكمة
لعزل ابي مسلم عن شيعته في خراسان،
فبعث له بكتاب،
قال له فيه:
"قد وليتك مصر والشام،
فهي خير لك من خراسان،
فوجّه إلى مصر من أحببت وأقم بالشام،
فتكون بقرب أمير المؤمنين،
فإن أحب لقاءك أتيته من قريب.»
إلا أن أبا مسلم الخراساني
ادرك ما يُضمره له ابو جعفر المنصور،
فتمرّد ولم يستجب لأموامر الخليفة.
كان أبو جعفر المنصور يعلم انه جالس على عرش متذبذب،
ويدرك جيدا نفوذ أبي مسلم في خراسان،
فلم يباشره بعداوة،
بل امطره بالرسائل المنمقة بالعبارات الخلابة،
والثناء المزيف،
ليستدرجه للقدوم إليه في العراق.
نجحت خطة ابو جعفر المنصور،
وقَبِل ابو مسلم الخرساني المجيء لقصر الخلافة
بعد ان أمّنه المنصور على حياته.
لن نجد،
أكثر بلاغة لتصوير أبي مسلم الخراساني
وهو بين براثن الموت في مجلس ابي جعفر المنصور
ممّا كتبه أبو العلاء المعرّي في رسالة الغفران،
حيث قال:
" والعجب لأبي مسلم،
حَطَبَ لنار أكلته،
وقَتَلَ في طاعة ولاة قتلته،
وليس بأول من دأب لسواه،
وأغواه الطمع فيمن أغواه،
وإنما سَهِر لأم دَفْرِ،
وتَبِع سرابًا في قفرِ،
فوجد ذنبه غير المغتفرِعند صاحب الدولة أبي جعفرِ،
وكل ساع للفانية لا بد له من الندمِ."
إذن خُدع ابو مسلم الخراساني
لأنه نسي
ان احقاد الملوك لا تُمحى.
أوعز المنصور  إلى حرسه
ان يختبئوا خلف رواق في مجلسه عند استقباله لأبي مسلم الخرساني،
وأمرهم أن ينقضُّوا عليه ويقتلوه عندما يعطيهم إشارة بالتصفيق بيديه.
أهان المنصور ابا مسلم وكال له ابشع الشتائم،
فأومأ أبو مسلم إلى رجله يقبّلها،
وقال مستعطفا:
«أنشدك الله يا أمير المؤمنين، استبقني لأعدائك.»
فدفعه برجله وقال له:
« وأي عدو لي أعدى منك؟»،
ثمّ أعطى الإشارة لحرسه فمزقوه بسيوفهم.
بعد ان قتل ابو جعفر المنصور ابا مسلم الخراساني،
خطب في الناس قائلا :
"أيها الناس،
لا تخرجوا من أُنس الطاعة إلى وحشة المعصية،
ولا تمشوا في ظلمة الباطل بعد سعيكم في ضياء الحق،
إن أبا مسلم أحسن مبتدئًا وأساء معقبًا،
فأخذ من الناس بنا أكثر مما أعطانا،
ورجح قبيح باطنه على حسن ظاهره،
وعلمنا من خبيث سريرته وفساد نيته
ما لو علمه اللائم لنا فيه لعذرنا في قتله،
وعنفنا في إمهالنا،
فما زال ينقض بيعته،
ويخفَر ذمته حيث أحل لنا عقوبته،
وأباح لنا في دمه،
فحكمنا فيه حكمه لنا في غيره،
ممن شق العصا،
ولم يمنعنا الحق له من إمضاء الحق فيه".
بعد ان تخلّص من أبي مسلم الخراساني،
سيعمل أبو جعفر المنصور على مجابهة الخطر
المُتأتِّي من أبناء عمومته من العلويين
وبالتحديد من الحسنيين
نسبة إلى الحسن بن علي بن ابي طالب.
يعتبر العلويون انهم احق بالخلافة
لأنهم من نسل علي بن ابي طالب ابن عم الرسول،
في حين يعتبر العباسيون انهم احق بالخلافة
لانهم من نسل العباس عم الرسول،
والعم في تقديرهم اقرب من إبن العم.
سيأمر أبو جعفر بإلقاء القبض
على زعيمي البيت العلوي،
محمد النفس الزكية وشقيقه ابراهيم،
اللذين تواريا عن الأنظار،
ولكنّه فشل،
فأمر بسجن والدههما
عبد الله بن الحسن المثنى بن الحسن بن علي بن أبي طالب
لإرغامهما على الخروج،
وفي سنة 145 هجرية،
خرج محمد النفس الزكية من مخبئه،
وأعلن الثورة على أبي جعفر المنصور،
وتمكّن من الإستيلاء على المدينة،
وحفر خندقا حولها لحمايتها
احتذاء بالسلوك العسكري للنبي في معركة الأحزاب،
ولكنه انهزم امام الجيش العباسي
وقُطع رأسه وبُعث به إلى أبي جعفر المنصور
ولاقى شقيقه ابراهبم نفس المصير بعد ان ثار في مدينة البصرة.
الخليفة العباسي ابو جعفر المنصور،
كان شديد القسوة،
مع كل من يحاول المساس من عرشه
او يخالفه الرأي،
فأمر بتعذيب ابي حنيفة النعمان
وحبسه وجلده بعد رفضه ولاية القضاء،
كما امر بجلد الإمام مالك
وهو عاري الجسد مكشوف العورة
لأنه روى حديثا عن الرسول لم يُعجبه،
ولكن ابشع جرائمه،
هي جريمة قتل عبد الله بن المقفّع،
الذي ارسل له كتابا أسماه، رسالة الصحابة،
نصحه فيه بحسن اختيار معاونيه،
كتاب
أزعج المنصور،
فأمر واليه على البصرة “سفيان بن معاوية” بقتله،
هذا الوالي كان يضطغن بدوره على ابن المقفع
فاراد قتله بطريقة بشعة،
حيث انه كان يقطع أطراف جسد ابن المقفّع وهو حي،
الطرف تلو الآخر،
مّ يرمي بها في النّار إلى أن مات.
يري الدكتور فرج فودة،
ان ابا جعفر المنصور،صاحب الحكمة القائلة:
"إذا مدّ عدوّك إليك يده فاقطعها إن أمكنك، وإلاّ فقبّلها"،
وإن دخل التاريخ من باب الجبروت
فانه تركه من باب رجال الدولة العظماء،
فهو باني بغداد والرصافة،
وهو الذي أشرف على تأسيس المذاهب الأربعة في الإسلام،
وهو حامي ثغور الدولة الإسلامية،
وهو المؤسس الحقيقي للخلافة العباسية.
أتوقف عند هذا الحد،
لأعود إليكم في الحلقة القادمة
مع العصر الذهبي للخلافة العباسية
الذي بلغ أوجه مع هارون الرشيد وابنه المأمون
ثمّ بداية الإنحدار
إلى حدود سقوط بغداد ومقتل المستعصم بالله اخر خليفة عباسي
على يد المغول سنة  "656 هـ  الموافق  1258م"
أشكركم  جزيل الشكر على المتابعة،
لا تنسوا الإشتراك في القناة
وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم كل جديد.
دمتم بخير وإلى لقاء قريب.